now we go to the U.S where Donald Trump
is preparing for his arraignment in
Miami on Tuesday as the first former
president to be federally indicted he
faces dozens of severe charges for over
a hundred classified National Security
files he allegedly kept after leaving
office
[Music]
still rallying blind Trump who's long
called the investigation a Witch Hunt
and remains committed to his campaign to
retake the presidency in the 2024
election
our Jackson prosco is in Miami with more
on the preparations ahead of Tuesday and
he joins us now from there Jackson what
can we expect
pharah Donald Trump has called on his
supporters to Rally outside the
courthouse here in Miami on Tuesday to
protest what he calls the boxer's hoax
but the fact is the indictment unsealed
by special counsel Jack Smith on Friday
is deadly serious and poses significant
legal Peril for the former president
those boxes of classified documents
recovered from Trump's Florida home
allegedly contained U.S nuclear secrets
and Intelligence on foreign Nations some
of the documents are so sensitive that
their level of classification is
actually classified itself Trump
returned to the campaign Trail on
Saturday where he railed against the
special counsel and the justice
department claiming the whole
investigation is politically motivated
but if you want a sense of How High the
legal Stakes are just take a listen to
Trump's former Attorney General Bill
Parr a longtime defender of trump in
many other investigations if even half
of it is true then he's toast I mean
it's a it's a pretty it's a very
detailed indictment and it's very very
damning and this idea of Trump as a
victim here a victim of a Witch Hunt is
ridiculous now much like we saw in New
York when Trump was indicted on state
level charges security outside the
courthouse remains a real concern except
here there's an added element because
Florida is very much Trump country it's
much easier for his supporters to get
here and make their voices heard some of
Trump's political allies are going even
further and they're essentially calling
for violence or in some cases even Civil
War that being said the Secret Service
says no extra precautions are being
taken for Trump's visits it's expected
he'll turn himself over to the U.S
Marshals for processing ahead of his
arraignments on Tuesday afternoon
far Jackson prosco in Miami for us
thanks Jackson